[Music]
i heard you broke up with brad who are
you gonna date now that you can date
anyone why is this an immediate question
to ask someone that just broke up i
understand that they're keenly curious
about body stuff as evidenced in the
following line penis in the foreskin
kind of luck so yeah go figure out what
you enjoy i guess but can we just let
people take a longer than 12 second
break between the end of one
relationship and questions about the
next you can be single is what i'm
saying this highly questionable school
art that is inspiring a love of
microscopes trophies open flames hookah
and magnetic floating chalices i'm
confused about my career path by simply
glancing at it let's go in and out 20
minutes adventure title of my
over-ambitious sex tape in this shot the
fleet isn't concentrating their
firepower on one location but when we
zoom in the firepower seems to be aimed
at this vulva's mass don't get me wrong
one should always concentrate on the
vulva's mass but be consistent why is
their skin flapping around as the wind
is pushing it back from the ship's
trajectory i get the g-forces do crazy
things to your face but for this amount
of gum flappage surely they'd have to be
taking some bizarre route out of here
and not the straight line that we see in
this shot
i can't do this anymore audio from the
tv since writer's room after sending
game of thrones final season somehow
makes it into the episode this was
insane that was pure luck i was not in
control of that situation at all
followed by jeremy and chris's reaction
to the birth of cinemasins also making
its way into a rick and morty episode
not closing all of your eyes when
receiving a massage you were right best
day spa in the galaxy enjoying whatever
this is with your grandfather these
things are just doing what they do in
the wild they love swallowing stressed
out creatures for 20 minutes and then
puking them up i think cats feel this
way about birds like it's their
responsibility to end their stressful
birdie lives consume them and then vomit
them on my pillow at 3am as if it does
anyone a favor so this sent us for the
unexpected visual memory barrage of my
long gone ottoman-obsessed cat oliver
oliver my whole body's like a baby's ass
diapered and rashy that makes no sense
try swallowing the giant ball of snot
that's dangling around in the back of
your throat it's disgusting says the man
who for 90 of his day is more bodily
fluids on his face than jabba the hutt's
gynecologist it's nice of you to let me
off the hook it's still unacceptable
behavior and i do regret it rick is
being extra nice because he's had all of
his toxins removed but that would seem
to overlook that some of the most toxic
people you will ever meet will carry
themselves with a kind word and a smile
yeah take that you came here for sex
tape jokes and left with life facts
suckers i'm real proud to be your
grandpa morty i guess this is on me for
enjoying this wholesome moment while
also realizing that the toxic elements
of rick and morty are ripped from their
consciousness do do i prefer this show
am i a sap trained by television to feel
better when everyone gets along like
puppets well you were flapping your
parasitic turd holster not specifying
what the turd holster is precisely so
i'm now unsure how to use it in
situations requiring insult slinging i
discovered the toxic equivalent of
electricity morty
i love the idea that there's a toxic
version of electricity even if it
doesn't make any sense i mean would
lightning just deliberately pick out the
nicest people to strike would a power
surge wait until you've nearly finished
a big project to short out your computer
and then do exactly the same thing to
your brand new computer just the [ __ ]
with you wait toxic electricity may
already be a thing now who can tell me
the common denominator of these two
fractions
you don't know or you're just bored
false dichotomies with the kids clothing
variety as your only clue you will never
discover the mystery of the current
weather pattern in the neighborhood if
we're all bored over here wouldn't the
common denominator be you we learned
that it's only the character traits the
individual believes are toxic that have
been removed but i still struggle to
believe that morty doesn't think being a
back-talking smart ass to his teacher
doesn't fall into the realm of toxicity
i do however know that i have a pretty
bad case of haven't taken you to dinner
itis this works oh sh the item on the
wall wasn't art at all it was an actual
trophy case well in that case i will
remove a sin because i called it art and
then madison back because it looks like
the rest of the trophy case is further
down the hallway but we saw much more of
it from a different angle earlier i
think i know what to do
morty holy sh what was the foam made out
of that made it so easy for morty to
snap it in half oh
i'll have a water but but you already
have wine so wouldn't the drink order
have already been taken or is that the
previous table's wine but why is there
wine at the empty tables what is this
restaurant look this is rick and morty
land so i'm gonna gloss over the fact
that these two 14 year olds are having a
first date at this fancy restaurant
instead of a [ __ ] arcade or something
but i refuse to believe that this
teenager would leave the house with
little to no battery on their phone that
is a step too far people hey rick are
you familiar with benoit technology the
[ __ ] behind rick and morty continue
to make me drop the ball when it comes
to resisting the urge to fall into the
annals of the internet just for the sake
of making sure i understand the whole
joke they're making they're all the bad
parts of us which by the way includes
our dishonesty but dishonesty can have
positive uses though an abundance of
honesty can lead to feeling like you
have to fill in the comment sections of
the internet with all the reasons you
hate something instead of letting people
enjoy the things they love you know just
as a totally random example no
is it wrong if i think this is kind of
hot watching an elder person force a
younger person to toxify themselves in a
garage experiment has rick and morty
asked us to contemplate morals a bit too
far this time
probably
did i ask for this huh did i
assessing threat to groin point uses a
defensive groin laser if it only deploys
after multiple hits to the vegetables
have been received
look either this door frame is made of
cardboard or rick's body is made of
titanium and yes in this world either
could be true but if i stop sending
stuff because it could be true these
rick and morty videos would be about
five seconds long carpet's so weak at
tears by hand or hands so strongly tear
carpet either way it's a sin taping the
horse head to the exterior of the frame
rather than opening up the frame to
subtly attach it to the photo directly
it's pretty disgusting so you'll have to
believe me when i say they forgot to put
rick's dismembered and eviscerated body
in this panel the monster stripping a
spine tube thing out of the center of
the floor with no rick and then suddenly
there's a rick
the random bowl of fruit on the bottom
of the table survives this what did the
booger version of you mean when he said
he was going to make the whole world
toxic oh i'm sure he just left that as a
clue so rick would know where to find
him once he figures out how to recombine
them both into one being villains are
super helpful like that it must be by
the individual's own definition of
toxicity the best thing about this
episode is that it doesn't just assume
that all's well once the things that you
believe are toxic about you have been
removed we can all be toxic in ways that
we're totally unaware of and it all
comes down to perspective damn you rick
and morty for once again having more
self-awareness and insight than any
cartoon about a belching scientist has
any right to be this moon tower morty is
the perfect heightened metallic
composition for the amplification of
beaming of toxic energies convenient
tower fitting the exact requirements of
the villain's plan is very convenient
kids this stock is a beautiful redhead
recently single not looking to date but
ready to fall in love creators of the
show went to the extra effort of
animating this apple in case this jordan
belmort impression didn't quite hit all
the [ __ ] notes on its own is this
organic
yes proclaiming the organicness of your
food is pointless but it isn't morty
chopping this carrot while neither
moving the knife onto the carrot or the
carrot into the knife levels of
pointless hey did you ever want to hold
the terry fold thinking that playing a
whimsical song will make me hang around
for the entirety of the cr wait what the
hell is a terry fold why does it make me
think of dinosaurs is this like a sexy
dinosaur song how did dinosaurs have sex
i suppose carefully is the obvious
answer wait is that the end of the
credits damn it
peter this this is a detox clinic you
can't vacation here let's go in and out
20 minutes adventure four to six days
later
hey uh you mind if i put on some music
not at all
the bird is a word
hey morty remember yesterday when i
couldn't play the trombone well check
this out
not quite my temple what's a knockout
like you doing in a computer-generated
gin joint like this
i'm out of my awkward state
john one thing i can promise you even in
this market is that i never ask my
clients to judge me on my winners i ask
them to judge me on my losers because i
have so few